dans le reste de l'actualité de ce 3
février également la levée de certaines
restrictions dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la copie de 19 le port du masque
n'est dorénavant plus obligatoire en
extérieur les jauges dans les lieux
recevant du public assis sont abandonnés
et le télétravail n'est plus que
recommandée dans les yvelines le taux
d'incidence a chuté de 25% sur les sept
derniers jours tout comme le nombre
moyen de nouveaux cas confirmés
quotidien les mesures de qui sont prises
par le gouvernement pour alléger un
petit peu les contraintes qui pèsent sur
nous elles elles sont basées sur des
faits scientifiques et donc je pense que
par rapport à cette circulation
épidémique qui baisse un peu et puis
pour aussi soulagé je veux dire on
l'a la patience enfin soulagé la
difficulté pour les français d'avoir
toutes ces contraintes aujourd'hui dans
les yvelines 81,6 % de la population
dispose d'un schéma vaccinal complet 75
% ayant fait sa dose de rappel et face à
cette évolution de la situation
sanitaire les centres de vaccination
s'adapte certains réduisent les plages
horaires comme à saint quentin en
yvelines pendant que d'autres des
ménages c'est le cas du centre de mantes
la jolie dorénavant installé à
magnanville une décision motivée par la
diminution des demandes mais aussi la
nécessité de relancer les manifestations
dans les anciens locaux les communes
nous soutiennent et donc là jusqu'au 31
décembre la commune demande nous a
fortement soutenu
et donc mettez à disposition le ménage
les agents de sécurité et la magnanville
nous remet pareil à disposition on a
également le soutien de gpso la
communauté d'agglo aujourd'hui on va
alors à peu près 3 semble un peu plus de
302 réalisé l'injection en moyenne
jusqu'à donc quelques semaines 700-800
trappe à nouveau dans l'actualité avec
la mise en examen du député européen
jordan bardella l'élu du rassemblement
national avait qualifié la ville de
république islamique
elle des propos qu'il a réitéré hier sur
le plateau de c 8 face au maire de la
commune dont il avait demandé la
révocation ainsi que la mise sous
tutelle de la ville je maintiens mes
propos trap est éminemment une petite
république islamique en miniature ce que
je dis c'est que tu rappes roubaix saint
denis la ville où j'ai grandi
et tant d'autres quartiers en france
c'est notre futur c'est que si on
reprend parents j'en maintenant la
situation alors ce qu'on connaît à
trappes on le connaîtra demain donc dans
d'innombrables villes françaises le
quart de finale de la coupe de france
opposant bergerac à versailles se jouera
finalement à périgueux mercredi prochain
la fédération française a tranché une
dérogation a été accordée car seuls
bordeaux possédait en stade normalement
homologué pour ce genre de rencontres
dans la région de quoi agacer les
dirigeants et blinois qui au tour
précédent n'avait obtenu aucun passe
droit pour recevoir toulouse reste
maintenant à régler le litige en
chaussant les crampons et en décrochant
une place en demies
chatou nouvelle la référence du street
art deux des six fresques réalisées
l'été dernier viennent d'être
sélectionnés parmi les plus belles de
l'année en france elle participe aux
golden street art 2021 organisé par le
site trompe-l'oeil point info les
internautes vont maintenant pouvoir se
prononcer et mettre la cité des
impressionnistes à l'honneur parmi les
38 autres oeuvres en compétition la
réalisation de vigny graffiti baptisé
diversité orne la façade d'un immeuble
de la résidence des marolles et l'ama
morphose de carlos alberto dh figure à
l'entrée du collège renoir